Oh
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
son sit there tending bar when in walks
a woman I've never seen before my wife
named chair now I don't know what was on
a while problem was but she just comes
barging into the past dreaming and
yelling at me
I tell us at all calm down calm down
chill out take a breath tell me what's
going on she says I was abducted and I
said abducted by whom and she says I
don't know just some secret science
organization or government thing I don't
know that's running tests on people not
like one look at her orange jumpsuit now
say you sure you're not just a janitors
hit the happy sauce pretty hard or
treaters no no I'm telling the truth
it's some sort of sick twisted
experiment that they run on people
they're trying to test them for
somebody's not said all right well what
kind of test do they run on yeah and she
said they're giving us all soot give you
a gun and the gunner can shoot holes in
the wall I said well lots of guns can do
that then she said no no this is the
kind of gum back you shoot a hole in the
wall and you come out the other side of
the wall
say you sure you haven't been hitting
the happy sauce and she says I am dead
serious
well of course I'm not believing a
single word that she's saying but just
for the sake of interest I also to keep
going and she says they run you through
all sorts of weird experiments were you
supposed to shoot the dog and little
balls of electric shocks and flow and
bias Buster get him in these little
other holes it's all about holes and
there's this computer this evil computer
that keeps talking to me and calling me
names and I'll say aha evil computer
that keeps calling you names like Val
9000 and she says no no it's Lord - Hal
9000 except it's a woman Oh course and I
of course as well why you why they pick
you
she says they tried to pick people that
nobody would miss that have absolutely
no impact on society and I said well
Cain what'd you do for them she said I
was a political radio talk-show host
when I'll disappear nobody notices in
fact nobody even asked is what
disconcerning actually and I said well
okay well hard to get out of there and
she said well the computer you know the
one that's alive and that's a woman's
voice she said it has different part of
his personality and it keeps these
different part of his personalities and
like these giant metal testicles and
also you were finding artificially
intelligent metal testicles and she said
yes is that so hard to believe so I'll
destroy the middle testicle she says and
I use the portal gun to get the hell out
of there and the whole line explodes big
explosion
I said then what happened well I tangled
in his place I could find which was here
just tell somebody what was going on and
I said alright well if this is all true
where's your gun with your magic portal
gun
she's as well I lost it how do you move
something like that she said well I sort
of shut the hole in a bridge and let it
drop and yeah I fell right to the middle
River and I said well why don't you fire
a hole in the bridge and she says I
can't help it what once your fire our
hole in the ground or one in our ceiling
you drop the gun
it just keeps falling and by god is
entertaining to watch it's the only
thing that kept our sanity that just
dropping things down the whole thing you
constantly fall and she said now there's
this portal gun in the river that's
doing I don't know what kind of damage
maybe they're shoots a hole in the water
the water will suck in that all the fish
will get with an L keep all this endless
a little bit we've gotta call the police
we gotta call the police and let them
all go and I said alright calm down
catch up with
took a few deep breaths I gave us some
water
start calm down sit
you look hungry why don't I get you
something here
piece of cake on the house
she committed suicide right there pulled
out a gun and blow her brains out I've
never seen anything like that I don't
even know what you got the gun hell no
she Rob's somebody on the way along what
and
you know I feel bad I don't know what
what's going on inside our head but in
all honesty puppies and golfing I mean I
offered her the cake she commits suicide
but both the liver and a florist in my
life I have no idea what I did and then
knew the phrase cake or death literally
meant cake or death she didn't even say
anything then say well no actually she
ditches she mumbles something right
before she pulled the trigger sort of
hard to remember but I think some along
the lines of the cake is alive
with a cake be alive what does she think
the cake was trying to eat us trying to
kill her family nutty as a fruitcake
Oh God become a well say that how
something might blow the brains out now
I don't care I bigger things to think
about for example did you hear that
introducing this new GP as called GLaDOS
it's supposed to be incredible you know
how a GPS never gets you where you're
going sometimes you figure might get a
line as trying to send you in the wrong
direction
GLaDOS tells you exactly where to go and
GLaDOS is going to take all of us to
where we need to be I'm looking forward
to that cuz I'm bad with directions
maybe that she'll woman go use graphs
and then we'll given us some direction
in life you'll have to pardon attack
traffic it's clever huh cor strange
things as a bartender there will strange
things in the pizza palace so I'll see a
lot of strange things as a bartender
pixal pass learning a lot
you